un nuevo hito para la humanidad Este
martes nació en República Dominicana
Damián qué Naciones Unidas considera el
habitante número 8.000 millones una
celebración de la diversidad para la ONU
pero con advertencias lo recién llegados
a la tierra encuentran un planeta en
emergencia miles de millones de personas
están luchando cientos de millones se
enfrentan al hambre e incluso a la
hambruna números
récords están en movimiento en busca de
oportunidades y alivio de la deuda y las
dificultades Las Guerras y los desastres
climáticos en 2023 India superará a
China como el país más poblado el
gigante asiático se enfrenta a un grave
declive de su tasa de natalidad y más de
la mitad del aumento de la población se
concentrará principalmente en África
concretamente Las Naciones subsaharianas
contribuirán con más de la mitad del
crecimiento de la población mundial
previsto hasta 2050 en Nigeria por
ejemplo la Edad Media es de 17 años
la creciente población en Nigeria se
debe a que no controlamos nuestra tasa
de crecimiento
si miras al norte son libres de casarse
con hasta cuatro esposas y cada esposa
puede tener tantos hijos como quiera
desde el sur sabemos que por las
dificultades económicas la gente tiende
a no tener demasiados hijos
el estudio de la ONU también refleja que
para 2050 habrá un 10% más de personas
mayores de 65 años con fuertes impactos
en Europa
somos ocho mil millones pero en nuestro
país Italia el crecimiento es cero nos
creemos que los jóvenes de hoy ya no
pueden formar una familia por una serie
de problemas con un crecimiento
ralentizado desde 1950 se espera que
2080 sea la década en la que el mundo
alcance su pico de habitantes con más de
10.400 millones de personas
en realidad dos tercios de la población
mundial vive en un país o área donde la
fecundidad es inferior a 2,1 nacimientos
por mujer el nivel considerado óptimo
para garantizar El reemplazo
generacional